have you seen these videos of people
rioting at a Russian airport looking for
Jewish passengers they searched buses
and checked people's passports let me
explain what's going on here this is
dagistan which is a Muslim majority part
of Russia many people here support the
Palestinian cause this region is really
important because Vladimir Putin
dedicated his early presidency to
fighting terrorism here Putin also likes
to use dagistan as proof of Russia's
ethnic and religious diversity but these
anti-jewish riots spontaneously breaking
out at an airport really does not look
good Putin of course is blaming all of
this on social media and Ukraine and the
West saying that they're to blame for
exploiting the emotions of the dastani
people and inciting this ethnic violence
so Putin might project a lot of strength
but in reality he doesn't have Russia
totally under control if you want to
better understand global politics follow
along for more